فيما خص روايتنا حول طوفان الاقصى لماذا
طوفان
الاقصى لقد قلنا مرارا ونؤكد اليوم ان
عمليه طوفان الاقصى يوم السابع من اكتوبر
تشرين اول من العام الماضي
2023 كانت خطوه ضروريه واستجابه طبيعيه
لمواجهه ما يحاك من مؤامرات لتصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه اطلقتها حكومه نتن ياهو
بالشراكه مع الاداره
الامريكيه من سيطره على الارض
وتهويدها وحسم للسياده على المسجد الاقصى
المبارك
والمقدسات
وحصار جائر على قطاع
غزه واستيطان يستشري في ارض الضفه ليستولي
عليها فكان لابد لهذه العمليه لتنهي كل
ذلك في اطار تخلص من الاحتلال واستعاده
الحقوق الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وانجاز
الاستقلال والحريه اسوه بباقي شعوب العالم
وتحقيق حق تقرير المصير لشعبنا واقامه
دولته المستقله كامله السياده وعاصمتها
القدس